il y avait la France un incroyable
talent ça a perdu hein ça a baissé en
audience c'est passé sous les 3600000
téléspectateurs perdus en une semaine
après hier il y avait moins de monde
devant la télé toujours veille de
weekend donc c'est un petit peu normal
et au programme encore et toujours du
champ de la danse et des mecs qui font
des trucs assez chelou et c'est ça qu'on
aime d'ailleurs mes cousins ont passé
une tête dans l'émission avec un numéro
d'épée et de tronçonneuse petite compile
des gens chelous de incroyable talent
hier
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est27 on revient sur incroyable talent
la France incroyable tal g non j'ai pas
aimé merci
Salut c'est quoi j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait beaucoup de numéros qui tournaient
au gag au mauvais gag et j'ai trouvé que
le jury notamment était extrêmement
sévèreéle qui m'a pas du tout plu un
moment qu'elle ditel la VO
elle a critiqué des papas qui étaient
avec leur filles je me suis mis à la
place des papa avec leur filles je sais
pas si on l' ça mais je l'ai des petites
filles é ven danser AC le papa et Marian
James a trouvé ça trôier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde donc c'est les vrais papas c'est
les vrais papas ils savent pas
danser les mêmes gamines qui arrive qui
enlève le cerceau en faux diamant et qui
disent au Père ouais enfin je veux dire
en faire quelque chose on est au 21e
siècle les amis il faut que ça avance il
faut que ça décolle on peut pas
continuer à creuser dans ce rayon là et
les filles réveillez-vous je te pose
juste une question tu étais pas dingue
de ton papa câge là c'est de la
niaiserie ça n'a rien à voir t avis
c'est pas le mien ce n'est pas de la
mignonnerie c'est de la niaiserie ce n
pas par opinion c'est fou et les gars
nous on s'enoule quand même sur ce
plateau pour des trucs bon mais eux
c'est encore pire c'est embrouille non
mais il s'embrouille vraiment pour des
trucs on s'en les steaks en fait c'est
bien de laisser ça je trou c'est la
seule émission qui est encore un peu qui
dit les choses parce que les to les
autres talent moi je su un peu d'accord
avec Mar déjà déjà elle a raison puis
tout le monde est gentil tout le monde
est super tout le monde a beaucoup de
talent là ça fait du bien de voir des
gens se faire défoncer un peu c'est gens
qui sent bon enfant c'est pas non plus
horrible ah moi j'ai trouvé ça violent
violent pour les papas dont je suis
violent pour les enfants on peut pas AER
les numéros
45s on peut ne pas aimer les numéros
avec les enfants mais là elle remet en
cause l'amour des pères pour leurs
enfants
[Musique]
elle trouve juste que le numéro éclaté
au sol droit de trouver ça nul
n sur une scè c'est que tu prêes au je
des
cri il y croyent pas dans les poli voilà
c'était
mign allez il y a un autre truc qui
s'est passé c'est Eric Antoine qu'on
aime beaucoup il a mis un TAC la France
insoumise et atf1 déjà que j'adorais
Eric mais là je tombe amoureux ah moi
aussi alors là j'aime bien c'est
flippant le j'ai pas du tout vu venir
l'apparition des deux danseurs au début
je trouve c'était une très très bonne
idée c'était un peu agressif ça me
faisait penser un peu à la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
un petit côté un peu comme ça mais moi
je m'attendais pas avoir des légumes sur
scène les artischud non plus alors ce
qui est cool Kilian tu portes le prénom
bon B de la star du PSG Kilian mais nous
on va pas te prolonger et je suis
absolument convaincu maintenant de cette
théorie du complot je pense que c'est
TF1 qui vous envoie pour nous faire
chier et pour [__] cette émission
magnifique très
drôleô j'ai adoré la VAN sur FR c'est
pas mal ça fait du bien ça vous le voyez
pas
dans ni dans
mastinger dans avec les star c'est le
jur
jeis désolé moi c'est pour ça que le
programme marche ça
pas tout Lee
[Musique]
ili c'est
pasumentae
[Applaudissements]
bien c'est le chameau c'est le chameau
qui se moque du Bard dit c'est toi avec
ta prochaine meuf euh merci on va
terminer avec le Golden buzzer pour
incroyable talon il était il était pour
trois soignantes qui se sont inscrites
parce que pendant la crise du covid elle
chantait tout le temps pour les patients
et pour détendre l'atmosphère bah
histoire touchante plus belle voix égal
golden buzzer
[Musique]
regardez
ahain F
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'ép
golden buzer golden buzzer vérité ou pas
ou ah oui évidemment l'histoire et et la
prestation et en plus par Hélène Segara
qui a passé elle l'a dit dans l'émission
presque 2 ans à l'hôpital qui évidemment
voulait saluer aussi les soignantes
c'était une séquence magnif oui c'est
pas la France a une incroyable histoire
c'est incroyable
talentou tu as entendu comment elle
chantait excuse-moi il y avait pas
d'histoire elle c'était vraiment mérité
c'est pas non plus
inoubliable mais bon c'est l'histoire
les ché oh ou soyez un peu sympathique
là oh arrêz de critiquer tout le temps
il y en a marre a raison a
[Musique]
raison les chéris on v vous montrer
aussi une émission que très peu de gens
on regardé hier c'était la vie en jeu
sur France 2 euh c'était avec Nagi et
Bruno Guillon et votre revient au jeu en
fait c'est Nagi présenté une émission à
l'époque qui s'appelait n'oubliez pas
votre Bross à et ben là c'est pareil
sauf que quand tu regardes France 2 tu
demandes si tu regardes France 2 ou si
tu regardes la vidéo du du mariage de
Tonton jacqu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regardez Bruno Nagi ouais ouais vous
croyez vraiment qu'on pense que c'est
vous B bah non non allez sortez de votre
cachette là venez dire bonsoir vous
allez bien que vous allez passer un bel
Halloween sur France 2 avec Bruno
Guillon et avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enj bon bien sûr catastrophe d'audience
pour votre revien au jeu 1,4 million de
téléspectateurs 7,8 % TPMP a fait plus
que votre vie en jeu hier que le prime
de France 2 et c'est vrai que on aurait
dit la Foire du Trône regardez en fait
bon voilà il a Nagi et Bruno Guillon ils
sont éclatés et à côté au niveau vanag
Gill verd c'est Gadel
Mali est-ce qu'on peut avoir Karina le
temps réalisé par Jonathan bien sûr
brono je suis en train de calculer sur
mon boulier ah le temps Jonathan c'est
drôle et là vous êtes en de mains euh
exactement en mercredi plutôt bah oui
mais comme on est mardi vous êtes en
demain je en demain tout à fait
excellent vous allez voir les les bain
de Bou sont très agréables et ben
impecca on regarde la couleur on était
plus proche du bain de Bou oh joli oh
joli c'est quoi votre film d'horeur
préféré la purge et c'est ce
soir bon c'était dur puis il y avait un
jeu c'était du MIM de dessiner c'est
gagn c'est de la course de trottinette
et bah je suis allé à la carmesse de mon
fils l'an dernier à la fête de fin
d'année il y avait plus de moyens que ça
regardez ang on fait tourner la roue
Bruno euh don il donne le sein il donne
le sein avec les
dents les dents de la mer waouh c'est
bizarre comme dessin ouais
alors peur des
mains votre but c'est traverser
l'intégralité de ce couloir sans faire
tomber une seule
BRI
un point dans le cercle extérieur de
point dans le
central combien ça don il a un mot
combien ça a coûté ce prime ça je pense
ça a coûté cher ça c'est un peu plus de
500000 € je pense ça va où l'argent du
coup puisque ça va pas tellement à
l'image voilà au producteur d'accord ok
et qui produit du coup un groupe de
production on AG je crois OK je sais pas
je pas les chiffres en tête regardz on
se retrouve dans
un